so my name is Manu I'm a faculty at
Stanford I am an MIT alum I'm delighted
to be coming back after almost ten years
and one of the things when Schuyler told
me about this conference I was thinking
are you inviting the right person and he
said no no no you should come now I see
the big picture so I'm glad I came there
is going to be no particular thread in
this talk I'll just share with a few
sets of things that we do you might find
it a little bit chaotic and then maybe
in conversation some of those threads
could get woven in and one of the things
that I'll try to do is do it a little
bit biographical just to share a little
bit of my time at MIT and how that
shaped some of the work that I do now
okay so this is so before I begin this
is my lab incredible group of people
that I get a chance to work with some of
our work is in the context of marine
biology frugal science global health and
then some of that is in from a context
of programmable matter and I'll leave
through them to show you some
connections let me start with this
picture in the conference about being
material if Lego hasn't been mentioned
it should
ironically I didn't grow up with this
beautiful material I only learned about
Lego in college and so I had a little
bit of a late-blooming episode I was
doing a degree in computer science but
was this weird kid who was thinking
about Lego from a context of complexity
of constructions that you could make I
found some of the internet never forgets
so I found this 2001 email actually
turns out the question that I had posed
there had been solved for biology there
are complexity theories in understanding
how biology builds things so long story
short if I had teachers like Ben and
Kasey I would have stayed doing
programming but I although I had a
degree in computer science
just couldn't see myself sitting in
front of a computer that got me to MIT
and I started thinking quite a lot about
physics of computation it turns out
these ideas have been around for a very
long time this is again another picture
from MIT some red circles are people
that you might recognize the define 'men
right there but there is a mistake that
ended up happening in the class of ideas
there could have been we could have been
way far ahead also in being materials
was the fact that physics of computation
was always about what are the limits of
computation although they recognize the
fact that all computation uses physical
materials it was not an advantage and so
when I got to coming to my thinking
about my PhD one of the biggest fact was
we can never go away from the fact that
the atoms on a piece of chalk or
electrons running around in your
computer will always have a physical
context why can't be actually utilized
to extend what computation could do so I
started thinking about fluids these are
actually photographs of real fluid
computers from the 60s and 70s and
ironically there were Rockets flying
around with that kind of hardware
because of course electronics was not
good enough at that time this is a this
is probably the world's largest logic
gate in which you can actually pass
through it it's all hydraulic and people
started pushing this down this was very
important work because it did not get
impacted with all the extreme
temperatures and environments and
probably the only equation in this talk
is ironically much of this work doesn't
scale down which is what you need to do
to build complexity primarily because of
the linearity of Stokes flow so when you
write down and you linearize when you
become smaller many of these equations
linearize and they're time reversible
and you miss out the fact that there are
no non-linearity so you can't actually
build computers so I wanted to change
that and the reason I wanted to change
that was this photograph this is Giacomo
the father of green chemistry and
essentially the father of combinatorial
chemistry is the fact that if you had
tiny little while he was running solar
chemistry's looking for dyes and
compounds that would survive the Sun and
I wanted to do this at a much much much
smaller scale so I don't have to rent
the balcony at MIT to do large-scale
reactions and of course this is an arts
conference as well so I want to show
this image and one day in a train I
noticed this image but I was thinking
about these sets of ideas and that is
the image which you all recognize that
inspired bubble logic the idea that
these little bits that could be
traveling around could interact with
each other with hydrodynamic flows and
quite literally that's what I build for
my PhD I haven't shown these slides
since 10 years but you get the point
essentially these are microscopic
entities ten to hundreds of micron but
they can communicate with each other
with this invisible ether of
hydrodynamics and essentially change its
course I'm going to skip this this is
there's a technicality to it which is
the technicality was asked by an
external committee member in my PhD exam
which is how are you ever going to
synchronize leave sets the fits so I
sketched on a piece of paper
this became the synchronizer although
there is a beautiful mathematical
structure to it it ended up not scaling
and I kind of put this on the side note
to eventually revisit this problem and
now almost seven or eight years we've
actually revisited the problem to now
build a second platform that now allows
to do synchronous computation using
hydrodynamics and fluids this is a
platform where you program sets of
patterns these are magnetic permalip a
turns and these are magnetic droplets
but there is no hand of God here these
droplets sense and interact with each
other too for example in this case build
a single bit of memory now these
memories are much bigger than what
you're used to seeing but at that same
time you get the point there is an
energy trap right there a droplet would
come in and the way you should be
thinking about these types of computers
is these are not computers to run
processing or code or the way you use
computers but these are completely
programmable chemical factories we can
put
do things inside these tiny little drops
which go all the way to nano leaders
almost the size of the volume of a cell
but then you actually program them
rather than using large-scale robotics
this architecture is scalable we can
start building all kinds of hardware and
I'm going to skip the technical part of
this because I was yeah I want to show
other things so just to show the point
that you can now do this not just with
magnetic materials but with non-magnetic
materials now these are pure drops of
water that could be programmed with this
way and if you're excited about this
platform we posted all our programs the
CAD tools if you want to have fun you
can also build the actual logic circuits
using Lego designers as well but at that
same time this is a completely scalable
family we will be announcing a
competition pretty soon with this
platform to build and design some video
games but that will there will be actual
physical Mario moving around so anyway
if you want to learn more about this
there is a little web site called
computing the fluids I want to switch a
little bit of a context to talk about
simplicity in programmable materials and
talk a little bit of a biological
context to this so the ultimate
programmable matter is life and one of
the challenges that we face today is we
keep teasing higher and higher
complexity in life and of course we're
making tremendous progress in terms of
when we will you know who knows maybe 20
30 years from now you'll be able to say
that we understand life but there are
aspects of life that can be explored in
completely abiotic systems which Skylar
refer to a little bit and I'll show you
this video this is one of my favorite
how many of you have seen this video I'm
just curious how many of you know what
that object is so this little object
right there that kind of looks like a
robot is a neutrophil cells right inside
your body and hopefully some of you
don't have bacterial infection but it's
trying to chase a bacteria and of course
yay the neutrophil wins otherwise we
would be in trouble this is a phenomena
called chemotaxis
where you have to connect sensing and
actuation to be able to sense where and
your enemy in this case is and then
completely reprogram all the motors you
know there are millions and millions of
motors in the cell to be able to move in
that direction and one of the context
was until this point before the work
that I'm about to show you this was
thought to be possible only in
hierarchical extremely complex
biological systems and I'm going to show
you an example of the simplest abiotic
system that demonstrates that phenomena
and we will do this in a context of the
video and since there are artistic
aspects to it I'll shut up and not talk
but or maybe I will talk this is a glass
slide what you were looking at is food
coloring when you put food coloring on a
clean glass slide first of all it's
active matter there is energy that it's
transfusing now you should question
yourself I'm not coming here and telling
you we've discovered a new source of
energy it's coming from somewhere but
the fact that these entities can
interact with each other this they're
chasing they have a identity so there is
a sense of self and you'll see they can
both identify and what are the context
of something like this is the system
it's so exceedingly simple that involves
my mind this is a property of all fluids
which have a binary composition what I
mean by binary composition is any two
chemicals that do not react with each
other but are miscible will demonstrate
a class of phenomena like this so I
spent four years staring at those videos
and thinking about them it turns out
this is a property of many non
equilibrium systems that they can act
both as sensors and actuators and
because I'm going to run out of time I
will also leave this as a puzzle there
is a YouTube video online that you can
go to repeat this experiment in your own
kitchen all you need is a clean cover
clip or a glass slide and some food
coloring and you should puzzle yourself
by toying around these ideas you can
make structures this should really
puzzle you whether this is truly a
perpetual mode
machine or not how many of you think
that this will stop at some point okay
the other one do believe in perpetual
motion machines so this will stop there
is a context of energy here actually
let's just watch it yes but what I want
you to think about and I'm not going to
explain is how are these things talking
to each other what are the signals how
do you actually transduce that
information as a signal into an actuator
and what we're discovering in many
non-equilibrium active matter these
mechanisms cannot be teased apart and
from a context of origin of life you can
start thinking about lots and lots of
complex entities have emergent phenomena
they're sensing and actuation is one in
the same thing and since I'm going to
run out of time I'm going to skip
something here and tell you two more
things they also have a sense of
reflection they can see themselves in
the mirror and one of the contexts that
we actually use these systems is to now
explore extremely large scale
interactions where we're trying to
understand magnetism how magnetism works
using ideas like this okay so I'll tell
you one little bit of the last story
which is the complexity that is out
there in nature itself and there is an
aspect of programmability here which is
shapes and sizes of life-forms so this
is a picture this is from our recent
work if you don't know this is what a
starfish looks like and now you might
ask you know this looks nothing like a
starfish this is a larval form and we
wondered why is it that these shapes and
forms existed the first way so this is
nature's architecture except we don't
have the codebook or asking the
architecture or if there is an architect
but one of the things that dawns on is
when you apply the lens of physics to
this this is what you see if I was to
expose what that shape was trying to do
it's essentially trying to program
hydrodynamics to be able to feed and
swim at the same time and there is a
universal law that we can write down for
these systems and the programming is if
I had a baseball I would have shown you
the shape of the scene
that you would code on a baseball would
program that structured the hydrodynamic
structure just like liquid crystals
there are defects that appear in those
bands and from that you would program
the complexity and one of the things
that we're taking this is to now tell
you the C of array of animals that exist
these shapes but hopefully we'll be able
to explain how these things are
programmed with a singular idea okay so
I am on my last stretch
I don't know how strictly I have to
stick to this clock but I'll try to
which is the other half of my life in
thinking about of course it's wonderful
for us to explore nature but what do we
share with a broader community in the
context of thinking about the previous
talk you know there are billion people
on this planet that have absolutely no
access to health care no infrastructure
and of course no access to tools of
creativity this is a picture from
Madagascar where we do some of our
clinical work and it takes me 12 hours
to walk from a road to get to a point
where there will be the places or their
villages and one of the challenges we
think about how do you really bring both
the the wonder of science to places as
broad as possible and at that same time
how do you really bring important tools
so this is another context of
programmable matter where we have
revived back the jacquard loom and the
punch card programming how many of you
have programmed a punch card computer
one two that's awesome this is MIT I
love it
I rarely get an answer so what's
phenomenal is we could use them to
program chemistry so what you're looking
at is the device that we're testing soon
to test in Kenya which allows us to do
programmable chemistry using these punch
card tapes to detect five species of
malaria and one of the contexts that
ends up happening is it's not something
magical
anybody can reprogram reach angley punch
change the chips to be able to do all
kinds of different assays
so rather than thinking about life
sciences and biotech being a big black
box and you press one button then you
get a red LED and a blue LED which is
the answer we're trying to really open
biotechnology to be accessible to people
at the same time it make tools
are important and one of the most
commonly known word tool that we have
scaled up is called a full scope which
is a microscope that you make by folding
paper I have a few and this is what is
an image that comes out of it anybody
knows what this object is I'm just
curious
in a context of inspiring art these are
diatoms something that you don't often
see but when you watch them live it
turns out the biology of how diatoms
glide is unknown but the fact that they
glide and they have complex behaviors
themselves and to me this is a tool that
I use for inspiration and problems that
I search for but it was very important
to build it and manufacture it in a way
that every single kid in the world can
have them currently it cost us around $1
to make when we wrote the paper I had
thought that oh you know when you write
a paper then it will get adopted and
everything nothing happens the next day
when it gets published so we made a
little Factory in the lab where we made
50,000 of them and asked anybody in the
world who would want one and we asked
them what they would do and that led to
the entire pilot program this is the
world map where they're distributed
around the world and this community
again coming back to Ben and Kasey's
Point does an incredible amount of work
I guess since I'm out of time that you
can check on this website let me just go
back to the last one this is some work
for Madagascar but we're not going to
I'm going to run out of time let me end
with this we can manufacture microscopes
or we can't manufacture mentors and this
is really where the community is as
important as the scientific tools that
we make is the idea of being able to
have a group of people be inspired by
the world around them we need to really
be able to do this and I will end here
yes
[Applause]